ventilation inadéquate système
électrique déficient inondations à
répétition moisissures ce sont bien les
dernières choses qu'on s'attendrait à
trouver dans un laboratoire pendant des
années chercheurs et scientifiques ont
dû affronter ici obstacle après
obstacles et un problème demeure le
manque criant des espaces comme si on
cherchait à oublier cet endroit qui est
pourtant devenu un pilier de la sécurité
selon les experts que nous avons
consultés la science est fondamentale à
la sécurité nationale et à la sécurité
frontalière
plus de 900 pages obtenu par radio
canada en vertu de la loi d'accès à
l'information exporose le même constat
depuis 2006 il faut un nouveau
laboratoire
relocalisation urgente perte de
productivité passé l'espace pour
travailler de façon efficace et
sécuritaire heureusement l'équipement ou
des preuves n'ont pas été compromis par
les dégâts d'eau sans ce nouveau
laboratoire des services frontaliers la
sécurité des canadiens risquent d'être
vulnérable à des attaques avec très peu
de compétences et d'argent vous pouvez
faire énormément de mal comme terroriste
mais le gouvernement est obligé
d'investir énormément pour faire contre
face à cette menace pourtant des
dizaines de documents préviennent même
que les scientifiques ne peuvent jouer
pleinement le rôle accru qu'il aura été
confiée depuis les attentats du 11
septembre 2001 faute d' espaces des
mises en garde qui tranche avec le
discours des conservateurs
premier rôle d'un gouvernement c'est
d'assurer la protection de ses citoyens
contre la menace terroriste
les avantages de ces nouvelles
technologies d'avenir seront grands
traces d'explosif matériel radioactif
armes de contrebande et scientifiques
doivent non seulement faire l'analyse
mais aussi évaluer et développer des
technologies de détection toujours plus
perfectionnés pour contrecarrer les
terroristes et criminels on va pas les
trouver en doublant par exemple le
nombre de tournées on va les trouver à
travers la technologie bi chiffres
obtenus par radio canada démontrent que
nouveau laboratoire coûterait entre 130
et 140 5 millions de dollars peut-être
maintenant fréthun de d'investir cet
argent dans
le développement
sur tout une analyse en profondeur du
budget de l' agence des services
frontaliers indique que seulement 37 %
des fonds réservés aux dépenses
d'immobilisation ont été utilisés depuis
2008 cela veut dire que plus de 686
millions de dollars ont donc été dirigés
vers les coffres de l'état et ont servi
à éponger le déficit de quoi payer plus
de quatre laboratoires sert des lois ça
coûte rien presque rien
ça veut pas dire que parce que on a les
moyens légaux qu'on est capable au
quotidien de faire un travail de
sécurité le gouvernement se défend
d'avoir mis le projet sur les tablettes
précisons que l' agence étudient des
options pour la relocalisation
éventuelle du laboratoire presque une
décennie après les premiers rapports
alarmants rien ne semble être prévu à
court et moyen terme ici marc godbout
radio canada ottawa